its thought sites like this isolated
former RAF base in Essex are being eyed
up by the government as places to house
large numbers of Asylum Seekers instead
of costly hotels
in nearby Wethersfield a pretty Village
People tell us they've heard rumors
unconfirmed the plan is for 1500 male
Asylum Seekers and they're not happy
they shouldn't be letting them anywhere
near us I don't think they should get as
far as being in this country to be
perfectly honest because they're coming
from other countries about 10 countries
why why do they all come right over to
us because we're soft touch this uh
approach of dealing with as an emergency
and panicking almost into saxing
locations that aren't appropriate away
from good accessibility good Services
local Services health health services to
schools
um just can't accommodate that kind of
scale of development
the government will hope the prospect of
being detained somewhere like this will
deter Asylum Seekers but it's difficult
to see how the threat to then Deport
them will be effective given that so few
have been successfully removed in the
past
Ali is from Iran and came to the UK by
small boat last year he says from
countries like his there's no
alternative way to claim asylum in the
UK what is the legal way do you think
that people who are danger in in their
home country can could go to any UK
Embassy and ask for Asylum no there is
no way to do that no one could choose
this dangerous way to travel and to left
his homeland to left his home country to
find nothing
whatever bold pledges the government is
making in reality a flight to send
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda last summer
never took off and the policy remains
stuck in the courts it doesn't explain
is where you're going to send them back
to so you have to have countries who are
willing to accept them at the moment we
only have six countries so what's going
to happen is where are these people
going to go and we haven't got the
return agreements we needed at least 200
return agreements with different
countries before we even attempt in
something like this
yet again the government is trying to
send a message that reaching Britain
won't be a dream come true for Asylum
Seekers the fact is no policy to date
has achieved that Lisa Holland Sky News
Essex